for harry styles and olivia wilde things
are no longer as it was since they
started dating
[Music]
and now the couple's responding to
negativity surrounding their
relationship that's right that is right
harry's rolling stone's latest cover
star and in the mag he shares his
feelings about critics who've questioned
their 10-year age gap and the validity
of their romance which began in 2020 the
singer says quote that obviously doesn't
make me feel good
stuff harry who was previously linked to
taylor swift and kendall jenner says
while dealing with online trolls isn't
new for him it's still uncomfortable he
says quote it's obviously a difficult
feeling to feel like being close to me
means you're at the ransom of a corner
of twitter or something i just wanted to
sing i didn't want to get into it if i
was going to hurt people like that
[Music]
but despite the scrutiny olivia calls
harry's fans quote deeply loving people
saying quote what i don't understand
about the cruelty you're referencing is
that that kind of toxic negativity is
the antithesis of harry and everything
he puts out there i don't personally
believe the hateful energy defines his
fan base at all the majority of them are
true champions of kindness
that's the dream and after dating for
two years olivia and harry seem to still
be going strong
just last week the love bird stepped out
for a date in nyc
check out harry reaching for olivia's
hand leading his lady out of an italian
eatery in new york city and getting
swarmed by fans the couple were in town
for harry's residency at madison square
garden
nothing more exciting and it seems the
pair are making time for each other amid
their busy schedules
just last month the stores told e.t
olivia and harry are quote packing in as
much quality time now as possible before
he hits the road again
adding quote they treat their
relationship with a lot of respect and
work on it like they would their careers
and that's exactly how the couple met
while working on the set of don't worry
darling
isn't it the greatest aphrodisiac it's
the easiest place to fall in love you
fell in love on a movie so
oh wow how to answer this question
um i think uh
man i i think i had a wonderful
experience being directed by olivia um
i think
there is a
something that obviously like acting is
is uh
kind of very uncomfortable at times i
think you have to you have to trust a
lot requires a lot of trust
our life together
[Music]
we could lose this
don't worry darling hits theaters
september 23rd
[Music]